ah
no
[Música]
buenas noches
silvia tiene una historia increíble que
vale la pena conocer a detalle y por eso
quisimos hacer este formato de
conversación y creo que al final para
ser recuerdo conmigo en que vale mucho
la pena abordar lo que has hecho con
mucho detalles yo nací en la ciudad de
mexico por el sur de la ciudad coyoacán
mi infancia fue muy este para mí fue muy
corta por lo mismo por mi misma
ignorancia por los saberes sexualidad
por no saber de derechos todo comenzó
cuando mi padre fallece cuando yo tenía
8 años ahí empezó mi mi infancia y ser
grande porque empecé a trabajar muy
joven el porqué porque viví violencia
con un hermano y con mi mamá no porque
ahí no tenía ni voz ni voto ni me decía
no y esto para todo yo tenía
culpabilidad de todo lo que pasaba
desde allí este empecé yo a
desde un principio la violencia desde mi
infancia empecé a trabajar muy joven
empecé este a llevar a casa este dinero
para que mis hermanos estuvieran bien
siendo la menor desde que trabaje a los
diez años a los diez años a los diez
años y luego todos los de asia también
empezó muy temprano así es y cuando
llegó mi regla los 11 años fue como un
pecado me golpeó mi mamá y de ahí yo
decía que la sexualidad de la mala yo
pensaba que era todo mi hermano más el
que jon con el que me llevaba él me
enseñó a usar una toalla sanitaria
hace hace unos días que platicábamos
hablamos de tus primeros 900 primeras
tus primeras relaciones que además el
tema de tener una pareja o de que te
gustara un niño muy jovencita era
también un tema difícil de tratar y
porque era como
un error no de tener un novio y era un
pecado que es un error y no debes estar
ahí el que merece al que estuviera ahí
en la esquina platicando por un hombre
era un pecado entonces lo que pasó a la
edad de 15 años iba a las discos empecé
a conocer gente de ahí conocí el padre
de mis hijos arturo y ahí me empecé a
relacionar con él en poco tiempo y de
ahí dije esta es mi salvación salgo de
mi casa a quedar a los 17 años y a los
17 años
tuviste los años no me casé lo único que
hice salí embarazada nunca pensé en un
aborto nunca pensé en nada sino seguir
adelante nunca vi que para mí fuera este
mi embarazo un pecado sino que defendí a
mi bebé mucho y fue mi hija la mayor
decidí tener a tu hija a mi hija y luego
tuve mi segundo hijo iniciales pero
iniciaste una vida de pareja a esa edad
a esa edad empecé una vida de pareja
pero sin saber que llegar a ese hogar
iba también a vivir violencia iba a
vivir todo lo que yo pensaba que era
algo maravillosa un maravilloso hogar no
fue así cómo fue tu vida a partir de ese
momento del nacimiento de su primer hijo
en los siguientes años con arturo
cómo era esa vida esa vida era de que él
tomaba mucho el me golpeaba vivimos la
violencia mucho tiempo en un tiempo de
cremación mi segundo hijo al año nació
tanto que no sabía de un anticonceptivo
no sabía nada me embaracé y el doctor me
regaña tú sabes de anticonceptivos de
digo no él fue el que me enseñó para los
anticonceptivos y él me dijo ya no vas a
tener otro hijo porque te vas a meter
más problemas
poco tiempo después de embarazo este tu
tercer me embaracé de mi tercer niño
allí nació mi tercer niño porque son mis
tres hijos en actualidad y allí nace mi
tercer niño empezó a crecer mi niño muy
pequeño tenía tres añitos dos añitos muy
pequeñito empecé a notar yo a mi esposo
que bajaba de peso continuamente y yo
decía bueno porque está bajando de peso
fui inmediatamente al doctor alí ex ahí
empezó el peso pero pero el peso bajó de
peso tremendo porque en un día empezó la
sudoración es y el colchón se mojó pero
mucho mucho entonces de 80 kilos de un
día para otro peso 35 kilos entonces muy
impresionante el síndrome de desgaste
que ahora se llama no cuando entró al
hospital un doctor me dijo este espéreme
allí hoy está la vez
cuando salí me detenga aquí está esta
orden cuando veo sida para mí la poca
información que tenía decidida era
muerte
ay sentí mucho miedo así te dejo en los
progresismos tenía sida cierto con papel
si mencionas a hacerte esta prueba se ha
de hacer la prueba y te vas a hacer una
prueba total tal un mes que pensaste tu
voz dijeron tú te vas a casar pero
también pues para mí nació mucho miedo
mucha ignorancia mis hijos se van a
quedar sin madre sin padre porque para
mí era igual la muerte de ahí empecé a
ir a girar mucho mi cabeza ahí no
terminó todo sino que al mes se entregan
los resultados salió este positivo y ya
me dice el doctor tú también
pero había en esa época tú eras
indeterminable y le digo como sé cómo
que estás en el ínter de no y si tener
sed y bolitas de cuánto tiempo va a
pasar pues no sé cuánto tiempo pasaron
cinco años me descuido y me descuidé yo
porque realmente esto pues los
en 1995 cuando empecé yo dije tiene que
haber información tengo que ir a un
lugar como alcohólicos anónimos como
buscar ese tipo de información no había
nada yo ya había ido a la sala de espera
donde estaba adrián gómez ramírez una
activista que se fue mi ángel mi
salvación
es externo del 95 si tú estuviste cinco
años en este estado debido interminable
y que hiciste digo tenías a tu esposo
recién diagnosticado tú también recién
diagnosticada que que hiciste que
hicieron me preocuparon muchos mis hijos
me llegó a la mente mis hijos y cuando
me dice el doctor hay que checar al más
chiquito su primer prueba fue espantosa
porque llora mucho y le dije pero porque
llegará es porque tú estuviste
embarazada y ya poder aportado el virus
esté yo creo que sí en esa época pero no
salió positivo mi hijo más chico y cómo
fue el proceso de enfermedad de artur el
proceso de enfermedad fue muy grave
porque ahí me dijeron que ya no iba a
vivir sino que a otro día sin amor yo yo
estaba con mi espejo y desviando su
respiración le dije bueno este ni se
muere ni nada tengo que buscar
tengo que buscar información
voy otra vez al seguro social
me quedo allí y me aborda mi amigo
adrián gómez que era un super caballero
para mí a pesar de que era gay para mí
fue un gran hombre en mi vida él me dice
sabes qué dice este te he visto muchas
veces aquí que tienes luego cáncer dicen
no te hagas está duda tienes y dije no
como sabes dice mientras al mismo
consultorio siguiente mismo consultorio
a bueno te voy a explicar las cosas así
de rápido como y exprés y tienes que
debe ser lista le digo por qué porque te
vas a venir conmigo a los congresos con
los congresos de los que estamos
haciendo y tienes que hablar como mujer
viviendo con vih ya me di cuenta que
tiene vih y tú también
knox ida porque no se hablaba del vih y
le digo no adrián es que yo no quiero
pues desde que quieras tienes que
empoderar te en este momento vas a
salvar muchas vidas y a futuro
vas a hacer una gran activista silvia
regresión un poco tu relación con arturo
pero mi relación con arturo fue que tuvo
una atrofia cerebral en ese tiempo desde
un principio le diagnosticaron la
atrofia cerebral porque ya había llegado
el virus al cerebro
pero logró mejorar se logró mejorarse en
el sentido de que vi varios médicos
particulares en él
había una doctora claudia granados como
la recuerdo estaban las tres y costaban
las consultas muy caras entonces lo que
hizo el vih en mi vida fue en lo
económico dejarnos sin nada sacar a mis
hijos de la escuela de paga y seguir
adelante entonces para mí eso fue que
quitarme el miedo y ya y atender otras
cosas y tener buenos aprendizajes con el
activismo y además dedicaste mucho
tiempo a cuidar a tu esposa así es fui
cuidadora de él porque necesitaba
cuidados especiales a los que tenía que
estar allí en el momento sus
medicamentos y todo y adquirir los
medicamentos en el extranjero porque en
ese tiempo con ácida ponían a letreritos
quien tenía el aceite y el ind y nabil y
yo lo compraba abierto
con pocas pastillas y así obtener el
medicamento como star tour hoy de salud
ahorita está bien de hecho todavía me
sigo haciendo cargo me separé hace 15
años este sigo yo con mis hijos bien
llevando una relación y también con él
no muy bien pero si lo sigo llevando al
doctor sigo haciendo los protocolos que
los médicos de líneas me dicen y sigue
vivo silvia y bueno regresando a adrián
que conociste en el hospital estamos
hablando una época en la que se servía
el dispositivo o en ese entonces tener
sida era discriminación inmediata en el
mismo hospital en el mismo hospital
llegaba y desde el policía a donde vas
voy con el doctor febronio a que yo les
decía escribo y con el médico internista
no tú enséñame tu cita allí fue mi
primer impulso también recuerdo que dije
tengo sida con permiso y me pasaba
ese fue mi arma también fue fue de
verdad mi arma y mi salvación es decir
que tenía vih y pues todo mundo comenta
diciendo eso pues si no me deja entrar
ya se me hizo tarde para mi consulta
y ahí empezó como a crecer esta semilla
en ti del activismo así es allí me
confunde un poquito te voy a decir un
lapso porque mi esposo se contagió por
mi sexualidad y yo cuando conozco adrián
algo impresionante para mí porque le
digo me dice yo soy gay y me fui con mi
ignorancia así en mi mente
dije no trae falda no trae nada
yo pensaba eso entonces también me
empecé a pulir en la equidad de género y
él me dijo conmigo vas a aprender muchas
cosas y de ahí empecé yo a aprender con
él y me empezó a pulir en las
terminaciones y todo este rollo no de la
sexualidad aprendí con mucho con mucha
facilidad con él porque me las explicaba
también que que yo llegué y dije ay no
de veras es algo maravilloso que
conocido a través de esto
y entonces empezaste a ayudar a otros a
otras personas que sufrían de lo mismo
que tenían que ya estaban en grados
avanzados con enfermedades oportunistas
que tenían un cuadro eso lo difícil
empezaste a ayudar a otra gente de la
nada así es porque vi a mi esposo y dije
si éste se salvó se pueden salvar todos
en qué sentido porque me metía yo
[Música]
y me metía al hospital
y en el hospital veía cómo estaban de
gravedad a veces por deshidratación se
moría entonces le dije al director vamos
a hacer una cosa porque hacía
negociaciones también de medicamentos en
el sentido y quiero esto para mi
paciente y quiero esto para el otro
entonces él ya era mi casa en la quinta
32 del seguro ahora que quieres ir ya no
pues quiero parece quiero cama para esto
por el otro entonces ahí fue cuando hice
una incidencia política muy grande en la
clínica 32 y ahí decirles los derechos
humanos de las personas que vivimos con
vih él me dice y qué ganas con todo esto
con que te pongas a trabajar con quien
menos cumplas y que no me lo firmes
entonces eso me enseñó adrián todo por
escritos silvia nada nunca interesa que
te prometa que te que aquí te lo plazos
entonces sí empecé a trabajar con el
director y me dice no te gustaría
ponerse ahora sí le digo pérate para que
te pongas tú también a pones de soros a
los muchachos y me metí a urgencias eso
fue lo más padre porque ya tenía un
respeto de personal médico el director y
hoy entraba como en mi casa y el policía
me conocía
silvia y después de trabajar este años
haciendo esto ayudando a otros pacientes
y tuviste un sueño y desee quiero que me
platican era un sueño a la mejor muy
lejos por ejemplo en mi casa los tenía
en mi sala recuerdo las colchonetas los
pone allí y bajaba a mi hija otra vez
mamá me puse yo me quedaba así es que no
tiene casa vienen del estado no tienen
que comer y hai mira yo si puedo con la
información y todo lo que les voy a
decir que van a hacer y diciéndole al
director que me ayuda a hacer sus
estudios sus paneles virales todo eso
para evitar enfermedades oportunistas
que no pase como tu papá yo quiero
salvar esta persona me decía y cuantos
más van a pasar muchos muchos y se
acostumbraron mis hijos que cuando
bajaban despertando a viajar había
personas esté tiradas en el suelo en el
sala y yo dije mi mayor sueño quiero
tener una casa grande
se me planteaba así y dije y la voy a
tener todo mundo no me quería y cómo la
vas a tener pues si cuestan muy caras no
sé pero yo la voy a tener algún día en
el trayecto que yo estuve ayudando a
compañeros a mucha gente se arrimó un
muchacho y lo apoye y le di lo mismo le
brinde ayuda y casa david se juntó
porque murió david
y david era una persona viviendo con vih
que le di cuidados de de alimentación y
le dé asilo en mi casa
y fundaste casa david de casada cómo
construir este caso estoy construyendo
gracias a lo desea tengo que conseguir
ladrillos tengo que conseguir este
cementos como me hizo el sueño posible
hf eso es y de alimentos me hace posible
impulso cada año hace sus fiestas
como agradezco que estos ángeles hayan
atravesado así como yo he apoyado se me
han atravesado mucha gente igual casa
del azar de repente me da su granito de
arena
[Aplausos]
cuánta gente atiendes en casa de abril 4
gente allí que se llena a veces hasta 15
20 personas recibo yo todo lo que es la
diversidad sexual y abro casa david para
que las mujeres no se queden calladas
que aquí en méxico no debemos de
quedarnos calladas y mostrar el rostro
porque ya en la actualidad ya no es el
vih un tabú
ya no da lo demás es como para mí si uno
se abre sacas muchas cosas
cuanta gente es atendido hasta el día de
hoy no no no tengo el número pero sí
tengo una libretita no sé cómo nuestras
100 mil a nivel nacional porque vienen
mucha gente y los hago que firmen y ahí
tengo los
[Música]
silvia son 26 años ya desde tu
diagnóstico y estos 26 años que has
vivido con vih pero pero creo que vivir
con vih ya no es lo más importante hoy
tu trabajo se multiplica y se multiplica
todos los días así es
al fin al final de hoy falta mucho por
hacer seguro pero al final de hoy estos
26 años que te trajo el vih que se llevó
el vih que ha dejado en tu vida está
este parteaguas el vih se llevó mi vida
26 años
y me quedé con 26 años con vih vivir con
dignidad y con la cara muy en alto y que
no vivan las mujeres con ignorancia que
saquen que saquen gac alcen la voz
porque porque realmente somos
minimizadas no hay tanto trabajo en
mujeres y hacerse la prueba sobre todo y
usar el condón que es lo más importante
es tu sueño que sigue para acá es la
vida y para ti que a dónde quieres
llegar para ver si llego' ya son 26 años
mi sueño más grande es hacer más
ampliada la casa y ver mi casa más llena
y que fuera esto circulando y está
circulando este casa david en hospitales
porque soy muy sonada en hospitales en
nutrición cancerología cardiología inner
nutrición secretaria de salud lo que es
este insiste ya soy muy conocido y en
los estados no se diga ahorita ni de
algo estoy trayendo mucha gente de allá
y también llevando la difusión de debajo
de los laureles que está hf conmigo
y hoy como como los en la vida de sirena
hoy hoy tienes una pareja hoy tengo una
pareja soy muy feliz tengo mis tres
hijos mis dos nueras mi nieta que apenas
acaba de nacer hace dos meses y mi hija
y mi yerno y mi pareja que es lo
principal isaías colio que no es este
vih
me tiene paciencia me tiene todo por ser
la más enojón entonces de repente ahí
tenemos algunas diferencias pero soy muy
feliz con el dibujo muy en paz sobre
todo la tranquilidad y la paz el padre
de mis hijos pues qué bueno que no le
falte sus medicamentos si sigo yendo
estoy llevando al doctor y ya sin la
incidencia política para que no le falte
sirve hay miles de corazones que hoy la
tenga gracias a ti muchas gracias y
muchas por ese tiempo de hoy claro
[Música]
me permite vivir
[Aplausos]